hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong i am your host
mark ellis and i am boarding a plane and
i have my tray table up and i am taking
flight
solo today that's right the little
teenage bird is flying from the nest for
the first time because jacqueline coley
is on assignment sometimes it's a more
mysterious assignment than other times
all i can tell you all is this is that
there's a big movie coming out and
jacqueline's doing a lot of coverage for
it that's all that i'm allowed to say
maybe next week if she joins us she can
tell us what she's doing or if she's
still on next week i'll have a little
more information but that's neither here
nor there because we may be down at
jacqueline coley but we're up not just a
special guest today we're also up a
producer or in our show producee who's
going to be contributing to the program
today because we're talking about some
brad pitt movies that may or may not
have been wrongfully labeled as rotten
according to the tomato meter three brad
pitt legendary movies from 1994 to 2004
that's what we're going to be covering
here today so each of us took a brad
pitt movie that is rotten according to
the tomato meter what's interesting is
that all three of these brad pitt movies
are fresh according to the audience
score it's almost like the audience is
seeing something in these movies or
maybe six some things that are in
between the waist and chest area that
the critics aren't seeing in terms of
brad pitt and the quality of these
pictures so the movies that we're going
to be talking about in no particular
order are legends of the fall
meet joe black and troy legends of the
fall from 1994 meet joe black from 98
and troy from 2004. actually no meat joe
black came out in november of 98 do you
want to know why you're going to find
out in just a sec but first let's bring
in producie lucy here so prudency lucy
you are here and we we were kind of
spitballing how to do a brad pitt
episode we knew that jackman was going
to be out we know that jacqueline dearly
loves brad pitt especially when he is in
a quentin tarantino movie fixing stuff
on a roof um you
are probably a brad pitt fan but i don't
want to put words in your mouth i'm a
brad pitt fan
my husband aaron and i both have
the same level of crush on him we not
only think he's one of the most
beautiful specimens to grace our earth
but actually one of
i you know it it's taken me years to get
here but i think he's one of the best
actors we've ever had
it's taken i don't think it took you
years ago i think it might have taken
him years to get there but now
he is there and i i think he's a great
actor academy award winner now so um you
and aaron that's that's each other's uh
sort of uh
hall pass is brad pitt so that's gonna
work well for y'all's relationship um
who i want to bring in now is our very
special guest who i've been dear friends
with for a long time i knew her first as
janine de bean and that's actually how
you can follow her on twitter where
she's doing a bunch of great stuff you
may know her as janine the machine from
her exploits in the movie trivia
schmodon she's one of the great
competitors in the history of the movie
trivia schmodown and now you can find
her as one of the hosts at the it's a
wonderful podcast feed it is janine
bryce our very special guest today
janine it is so great to see you and to
talk about movies with you under i would
say less pressurized circumstances than
you and i are used to pretty excited for
that and excited we're talking brad pitt
he definitely made the high school
binder so you know i am a fan uh great
actor for sure he's a risk taker whether
it be eating on camera you know just
kind of going with it uh
trying a weird accent which we will
probably talk about today uh he just
goes for it so i really appreciate that
about him
don't uh lucy at some point i'm gonna
have to sneak some sort of movie trivia
here at the end for janine and and you
can play as well so i lose i
automatically lose
[Laughter]
i don't know you all seem like some
pretty big brad pit stands and there's
obvious reasons why
folks would be fans of brad pitt but
then there's also the movies themselves
which we're going to get into and break
down so the way that we usually do it
here on rotten tomatoes is wrong not
every week but we usually like to give
you a synopsis particularly if it's a
movie that maybe not everyone has seen
and for these three movies they vary in
popularity as far as brad pitt canon
goes and i would have to say that janine
i think the movie that you selected for
this episode is probably the best known
of the three as far as like brad pitt
mythology right
yes this is kind of his big introduction
into leading man status i'd say and so
you're what is your movie and just give
us a quick log line as to what it's
about
i'm talking about legends of the fall
from 1994
um
very romantic brad pitt in this film it
follows the ludlow family in 1900s
montana on this big sweeping ranch
and
some division happens in the family
dealing with loss and love and and lots
of drama so
love loss and drama and part of that
drama is that it didn't quite make it to
fresh on the tomato meter 58 rotten so
it's so
so cool it's right in that spaceballs
range um producing lucy you're
millionaire
yeah what's your brad pitt movie and
what is it about
troy my friends now if you've read the
iliad and the odyssey which i have not
you're going to be good to go about what
this movie's about because it's
ultimately about achilles the famous
greatest warrior of all time who went to
tr to troy to actually help get helen
back in the movie we have agamemnon
who's played by succession's brian cox
with the most
stellar wig of all time his brother i'm
not going to be able to pronounce his
name is played by brendan gleason and
ultimately brennan gleason's character
it's like melanis or something
melanie
she's got me so his wife is helen she
gets taken by my least favorite
character in the whole movie paris
played by
orlando bloom
and his brother's hector and they are
the princes of troy so next thing you
know agamemnon and mendeleus
are gonna go fight in troy but achilles
works for agamemnon and doesn't want to
and it's a bunch of hot sweaty men both
literally and figuratively on the
beaches of troy in grecian leather
you know looking nice while they stab
each other's eyes out
and ultimately achilles biggest goal in
life is to be remembered through the
ages so even though he dies at the end
of the movie in a really lame way by my
least favorite character paris aka
orlando bloomworst actor ever
um we do in fact remember his name so
it's incredible and the only thing
missing from the movie is phil the seder
from disney's animated hercules that's
my only complaint
and that's it that's the movie
i mean look it's a lot to break down
troy and so i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
beat up on producing lucy too hard for
having an in-depth synopsis because that
is
you're taking the the entire iliad and
trying to break it down like many a high
school student has failed to do so
i feel like that was not just a great
coverage of the movie troy but also of
like that was a good eighth grade book
report and i think i'd give you like at
least a b plus
to say that like you read the iliad so
my movie for reasons um about the film
itself and also other reasons is meet
joe black and that came out in 98 and it
is sandwiched in between
actually no this is the worst rated
movie of any of the three we're talking
about today shock troy is 53 so at least
you know fresh adjacent mitchell black
is 45
rotten and this is the story of death
but death has never looked better this
is a sexy grim reaper and it's played
obviously by brad pitt who falls in love
with claire for lonnie and uh wouldn't
you know it she's a human and so he sort
of wants to strike up this romance and
so he uses her daddy played by anthony
hopkins's bill as a conduit is sort of
unwittingly so but there's some things
that bill maybe can use joe for and joe
can use bill for and so that's sort of
our adventure and i say adventure very
loosely because this movie is about
three hours and
boy do you feel the three hours but
should that mean that it's 45 rotten
that's what we're getting into today
here on the show so we got lucy we got
janine we got me and now we have
tim ryan our expert review curation
manager who is going to take us through
what the critics were saying about these
three movies at the time of their
release at the decade of their release
so
brian hit the music
all right today we're going to discuss
three movies that all drew mixed reviews
from the critics but still help to
solidify brad pitt's status as one of
the biggest movie stars in the world
let's do this in chronological order
legends of the fall from 1994 is rotten
at 58 on the tomato meter with 57
reviews and it has an 87 audience score
meet joe black from 1998 is rotten at 45
with 49 reviews and it has an 81
audience score and troy from 2004 is
rotten at 53 percent with a 73 audience
score and for the record the best
reviewed brad pitt movie is moneyball
from 2011 which is certified fresh at 94
percent the worst reviewed is cool world
from 1992 which is at 4
so what did the critics have to say
about some of these rotten brad pit
films in a fresh review of troy sean p
means that the salt lake tribune wrote
if you feared pitt would be too
lightweight more pacific calm than
aegean storm his performance here will
convince you however in a rotten review
of legends of the fall janet maslin the
new york times wrote mr pitt's diffident
mix of acting and attitude works to such
heartthrob perfection it's a shame the
film's superficiality gets in the way
so that's some brad pitt i will now hand
control this podcast back to jacqueline
and mark
take it it's yours
back to you folks
uh tim always pepperin in the references
thank you tim for what the critics were
saying at the time of the release of
legends of the fall meet joe black and
then troy in that order so without
further ado let's get into movie talk
and i should introduce brian our
engineer on this episode here too for as
brad pitt stan brian so brad pitt stan
brian hit the music
let's just think about brad pitt in
general janine when did brad pitt first
come across your radar and do you have
like a favorite favorite brad pitt movie
of all time probably the movie that
really kind of got my attention with him
was probably seven
yep
so
that's kind of a favorite of mine uh
also love interview with a vampire it
was kind of this whole him and tom
cruise in this rivalry for for my heart
at the time
uh so yeah interview with vampire and
and and seven were kind of the the
mainstays for me really discovering brad
pitt yeah lucy it's it's like brad pitt
had those those two lives in the early
to mid 90s where everybody discovered
him in the early 90s is like oh it's
that sexy guy from thelma louise or he
like pops up in true romance and then
you actually get to see him act in
movies that janine's talking about with
seven and with the interview of the
vampire and by the way the rivalry
between brad pitt and tom cruise the
winner of that is obviously christian
slater thank you he's also an interview
with the vampire i want to give
cece
we need a christian slater episode if
that's neither here nor there lucy i
know you're a brad pitt fan as well when
did brad pitt first come across the lucy
meter
so my earliest memory of watching brad
pitt was actually the movie this is this
will paint a picture for young lucy's
little life here was the movie
california
yeah where he's like a murderer
with a camera so dark
california with a k so that's my first
memory of it and i remember being first
off like drawn in by him just like
physically because how could you not be
but
then the movie really messing with me
because i was like wait this band is
really frightening
and i don't know if i have a favorite
brad pitt film ultimately if he's in a
movie i'm gonna love it another early
memory i watched the movie a devil's own
where he plays an ira terrorist
ultimately um and and he's a terrible
accident in that film it's with harrison
ford he comes to the united states and
stays with harrison's family it's very
strange
um
and i find that he often dies in his
films but
i think a devil's own might just for
nostalgia reasons be one of my favorite
movies even though i know it's not like
one of his best performances
well you get to see him and harrison
ford i mean nobody's going to complain
about that in the same way the interview
with the vampire yeah it's cool to see
vampires thrown around new orleans but
it's also awesome to see like brad pitt
and tom cruise together for me i i
remember cool world trailers i remember
like hearing about this movie cool word
cool world and thinking like is this the
next roger rabbit i had a poster of cool
words you had
did you see the movie i've never seen it
i did
it's it's weird and not good but i don't
know i just was brad pitt and he was
gorgeous and cartoons and
doing crazy things
it's the movie that taught us that you
can take live action and animation and
blend it and it doesn't always mean it's
going to be who framed roger rabbit or
even space jam sometimes you just missed
the mark um i can't remember the first
time i liked brad pitt i can say that
was ocean's eleven because you know
there's just this thing when you're in
school in middle school to high school
every girl janine loved legends of the f
if they made legends of the fall trapper
keepers every girl in 7th through 10th
11th 12th grade would have had them and
so i think just instinctively guys are
like oh that's what the girls are into
i'm gonna go over here and watch i don't
know
bruce willis and sylvester stallone blow
stuff up so i was never into legends of
the fall but watching this movie i see
the appeal of it not just from like a
brad pitt sexy standpoint but like why
why why is legends of the fall your
movie that you think that folks need to
check out maybe has been done an
injustice on the tomato meter um it's a
very simple story but uh with edward
zwick directing it feels very epic and
grand and sweeping
um there's so much to look at you're on
this beautiful ranch you see like the
snow-capped mountains and the hills and
the cliffside so it's a gorgeous
romantic setting in general
um
brad pitt gets like three epic like
entrances in this movie
so
you know i get the appeal for every
teenage girl at the time um and it's a
heartbreaking story uh
i'm a huge fan of romance i can find
romance in any story like troy there's
so much going on but my beeline is like
the brussels and achilles romance so
like
that's you know what captured my heart
the whole twist and the drama of her
kind of coming between these brothers um
so yeah the soapiness of it is totally
my totally my vibe so uh yeah just the
soapy drama the sweeping epic of it all
it's kind of giving you several genres
history a war film a romance film a
dramatic film so you're getting a lot
with this movie so definitely i don't
know why it's so low it's great
and
edward wick has like his other films are
pretty high like i think glory is like
94
um
and last samurai is like 63 so you know
he's a great director i'm not sure why
his of this his historical film like his
others just is so low i'm glad you hit
on that because lucy if you look at the
critics consensus on rotten tomatoes and
i was looking at some of the reviews at
the time from legends of the fall every
one of them is praising edward zwick as
a director because like janine said he
does make this movie feel
so epic and so huge even though at its
heart it it's it's it's a soap opera
right i agree with everything that you
guys are saying and and
i think
what's interesting to me is the thing
that captured me okay i'm a basic girl
in a lot of ways i was very i'm very
taken by um three very handsome men
aiden quit aiden quinn anthony hopkins
oh
and and brad pitt sorry henry thomas
you're not my type but um
i was pulled and
sorry elliot
yeah sorry baby
go home all right go on that spaceship
with him at the end of the movie and
we'll be fine um sorry no i'm just
kidding but i think the same things kind
of pulled me into that film and it's
confusing why critics didn't like it
because i believe it was also oscar
nominated three times one for best
cinematography and
i really do love sort of sweeping epic
films you know um and this one i mean it
really does have everything so you're
kind of like what i don't understand
like why the critics hated it in
particular and it's like was it brad
pitt that they hated or
you know because he always had to kind
of rebrand himself because he was always
taken as like the pretty boy but he
actually is a killer in it he's a good
actor in this movie aidan quinn is
incredible i believe everybody's
relationship so i don't know i don't
know what the deal is ultimately i think
that with brad pitt and with legends of
the fall if you go back to 94 where he
was is i think that particularly in the
90s we like to put movie stars in a box
where it's like you're either this or
you're that but you can't be everything
and so because he wasn't yet a
full-fledged movie star i think a river
runs through it might have been the
closest thing to like the you know the
big time movie that that he was in but
that was also
a similar feel like i would get a river
runs through it and license of the ball
confused sometimes where it's like wait
is that from this movie or from that
movie that one yeah
jeannine what's the scene that's
separate what's the scene that you could
put on in the legends of the fall you're
like okay now i know i'm not watching
rip runs through it and i know i'm
watching legends of the fall like what's
your favorite scene to go back and
revisit that movie well i did mention
several epic entrances that this
character that his character tristan
makes in this movie
one of them involves rushing in with a
herd of wild horses uh but probably the
first entrance the first time we see the
character of tristan played by brad pitt
in this movie he's coming over this hill
he's just killed an animal so he's
bringing his fresh kill he's about to
meet his youngest brother's fiance
and it's kind of the click of chemistry
between uh the character susanna played
by julia ormonde and
uh tristan and
how edward's what kind of frames it he
cuts everyone out of the frame so you're
just kind of locked on the two of them
and the looks they're giving each other
and i'm totally living for it and just
that gif of him just you know pulling
his hat in the water kind of sprinkling
up like it's perfect so just the
introduction the first introduction of
that character is very memorable for me
so this is tristan
and does he speak english
just
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's fin cannon
it's a pleasure to meet you
i hope you and
ugly here find every happiness together
[Music]
don't mind my brother your uh dog has
more breeding than he has
lucy i loved hearing you uh to be a big
supporter like i am of of brad pitcher
but aidan quinn is so underrated as a as
a performer he's been in everything it's
been around for years he was great in
june thank you the proclaimers and and
he's also great
in this i mean
he's the guy never misses aidan and i'm
not just saying that because he's in the
wake
based movie the fifth quarter which i'm
sure you can check out on i don't know
maybe hallmark has a streaming channel
but you get like the harsh winters in
this movie and you get the actual wars
in this movie and it feels like aiden
quinn is just the leader of this pack
yes oh yeah and and i think to you know
i
he does so well in this film because i
kind of hate him the whole time and i
don't know if other people feel that way
but i really wanted susannah and tristan
to get together julia ormond and brad
pitt's characters it's like yeah you
know the for you know and they end up
together and i was just like you bastard
and she killed herself because of you
and but you also feel bad for him you
also feel kind of bad for him because
it's established early on that he that
tristan is the favorite of their father
um he's the golden child and so
you understand his resentment you
understand why you know he feels the way
he does and why he does the things he
does so for me i can kind of the way he
plays it i i i'm like oh he's such an
ass but i also kind of sympathize with
him because well true what aiden quinn
is doing right and that scene too i
think it kind of sets it up because
doesn't he don't the actions when
they're at the war because it's alfred
is aiden
yeah and there and then it's henry
thomas's character he's samuel
so he ultimately doesn't he send samuel
like accidentally to his death
in the war scene
is
so samuel is supposed to kind of stay
behind and translate something and
tristan goes to
visit alfred because he's been injured
and then they get word that someone
who's supposed to take a message
couldn't and samuel volunteered and went
with while they were both away and yes
and then he dies
he's trying there's a lot of family
pressure there's a lot of family
pressure to be the hero plus he saw an
alien rig up a communication device when
he was a kid and he's like well i just
got to get a message across state line
how hard can this be and it ends up
being his his life
and that's a great that scene too that's
one of the i think that's one of the
scenes where you're like when brad
pitt's like holding like uh and you're
just like okay this movie slaps
and uh another one too i think that's so
good and you're just devastated
is the death of isabel 2 oh my god you
know it's accidental and brad's reaction
this is where i'm like brad pitt is so
not just a pretty face he's so good yes
and the and the like what's wrong and he
looks behind he goes to her and she's
just like oh and he has a bullet here
and you know the moment it happens
because the baby just starts crying and
then you hear you know her mother scream
out and yeah it's it's it's totally and
the reaction of the like it's the police
officer guy like the little gay little
banyan brothers or whatever their names
and their and they're just kind of like
so smug
and you're like brad i hope you kill all
of these people
you know it's it's interesting y'all
bring up that scene because i was going
to highlight that as as my sort of
parting question with this movie is is
it a good performance by brad pitt
because again like he started out as
this guy who i think a lot of people
just had us like a pinup model and then
we obviously know him as an award-level
actor now every time he's in something
is he great in legends of the fall or do
are you just watching the progress of
somebody learning their craft he's great
in this film he's showing so much range
and he has the opportunity to do so many
different things so you see the
fun-loving side of him the adventurous
side of him with his brothers and the
camaraderie between the two of them um
you know when samuel goes to him for
advice about his first time with
susannah and just kind of that whole
conversation that you really feel he has
a great scene with everybody so that's
like his scene with samuel he has that
really uh great scene with alfred where
you know alfred's telling him he has to
marry susanna and that you know alfred's
telling him he can't make her happy and
that whole kind of exchange between the
two of them uh you know alfred accuses
him of getting samuel killed and and you
know
that that just hits a nerve for tristan
that whole scene so he has great strong
scenes with every character great
chemistry with every character you know
he goes from this happy-go-lucky wild
adventure type guy to once samuel dies
he you know feels his guilt and he sinks
into this kind of madness you know you
see him go scalp a bunch of guys after
that and um even when he finds a little
bit of solace with susanna he kind of
gets some ptsd and and just reverts back
into this
kind of static depression that he has to
kind of take off so the way he portrays
just this range of emotions uh and then
kind of his peaceful time when he gets
with isabelle too uh and then back to
kind of this wild man again so he he's
he hits the gamut of so many emotions uh
so early on in his career doing this
movie so i think it wasn't just a pretty
face he definitely proved a lot acting
wise in this movie he had a lot of range
and did a lot of different things and i
believed it was very believable you
really felt the pain of the moments he
was going through the curse of brad pitt
being somebody that's that good looking
and but also like really loving the
craft of acting
and having to kind of prove like i'm not
actually just here to look nice
and i think he's got a good cry face a
lot of people don't have a good cry face
who can sexy cry like that not this guy
i've seen myself in the mirror it's not
good
i'm horrible i turn into a tomato and my
face swells it's horrible but it's just
like let me come comfort you brad don't
shed that yes definitely like susanna
kissing his head and holding him
hey darling it's okay
so it feels like i think i know janine's
answer lucy are you on the the janine
wagon where it's like no this is
definitely a movie that has been done an
injustice by the tomato meter that it
should be fresh
this is so wrong the score i agree with
the audience score for sure this movie i
mean and and even like the academy
recognizing it or you know nominating it
three times like hello
you know these are people that are like
what the hell
were they they just had a bad day when
they saw the screening
the thing that surprised me when seeing
this movies i i couldn't even tell you
if i'd seen this movie starting to
finish until prepping for this episode
is how it does it's not just like a sort
of sugar-coated fairy tale about war and
oh these brothers going off to war
together it does show the horrors of war
how war sticks with you long after the
battles are done and again 87 percent on
the audience score so this is the
highest rated movie according to both
the tomato meter and the audience score
of the three pictures we're talking
about today and so it also gives us a
very easy transition into the next movie
because meet joe black also stars not
just brad pitt but also sir anthony
hopkins
and so this is the movie that i brought
to the conversation not to bore
everybody but because i celebrate this
movie for two reasons one the movie
itself i feel like was a big swing i'm
not sure if it connected the way that it
was hoping to do but i like the idea i
think this is cooler than like a city of
angels where it's easy to be an angel
who meets meg ryan falls in love with
her you're freaking death man you are
the grim reaper we're talking the
seventh seal we're talking bill and
ted's bogus journey you are the
the epitome of what it means to cross
over into the next life if there is one
and death would know that better than i
would but this death is like you know
what i kind of sweet on somebody now and
i was really inspired by anthony hopkins
and if there's a guy to inspire death to
want to do something different with his
existence probably is going to be the
words of anthony hopkins and so anthony
hopkins is talking to his daughter about
hey hey don't you know lightning is
going to strike and you're going to meet
that somebody well lightning did strike
and boy did it ever because now death is
falling for and death now
as
anthony hopkins clumsily gives the name
this is joe black who's now on earth and
is like i'm gonna give this thing a shot
very clumsy it's kind of like me at a
dinner party he's all thumbs can't
really use a fork or a knife all that
well but he can make love with the best
of them so
oh my gosh
it becomes this very long-winded sort of
romantic diatribe but i think there's a
lot to take out to meet joe black before
i turn it over to the ladies here i do
have to give you the other reason why i
love talking about this movie and it's
because i paid to see this movie in 1998
three times and i i bet janine knows the
reason why i paid to see the movie um i
paid to see this movie not once i don't
even know if i stayed at all to see the
actual movie but because the trailer
star wars episode one the phantom menace
was attached to meet joe black and so it
was either right before thanksgiving or
during thanksgiving weekend when me and
it wasn't just me folks a lot of people
went to go see meet joe black so they
could get the first look in the theater
of the new star wars movie and i'm gonna
say
best eight to ten bucks i spent that
entire fall because
man that's still one of my favorite
trailers of all time every legend has as
a beginning every story has a whatever
first step it's great every journey is
the first step so that's another reason
why meet joe black just kind of gives me
the feels um did i watch
the phantom menace trailer again before
meet joe black this time no i didn't
because i didn't want because metro
black had to follow that for three times
and i thought that was unfair to do to
the grim reaper and anthony hopkins and
the claire furlani so i do find
redeeming qualities with this movie i
think it's better than the 45 percent of
the tomato meter i would put it right
around tomatoes is wrong but i would say
i'd put it right around like 60 so i'm
just gonna get just too fresh janine how
do you feel about mr black well my
brother was obsessed with this movie he
asked me to borrow some allowance so he
could buy the big vhs2 taper of this
movie oh
yeah so um i watched it several times
growing up and i actually you know me my
romantic self loving loving romance
films i definitely got into it and of
course brad pitt just being gorgeous and
also just having this really sweet
child-like uh wonder about everything
like the whole peanut butter scene is
just adorable he's just being so cute
but also very kind of sophisticated um i
love the score of this movie as well the
music was good i i would say the the
music was was it thomas stanley howard
or whatever his name is thomas newman it
is uh thomas newman is yeah randy
newman's cousin is the composer yeah and
so the music did stand out but i also i
like that you bring out that that lucy
jeanine kind of references the fish out
of water-ness of brad pitt on earth kind
of reminded me of when we get wonder
woman out of temescara and it's like you
got to kind of interact in the real
world just give me a little bit of those
shades so i kind of appreciated that oh
my gosh yeah i think the peanut butter
scene too that i'm just sitting there
going like you're the most adorable
little guy in the whole world
and then i said little death oops
speaking of little deaths uh the sex
scene is i think one of the best sex
scenes ever it when i was younger i
first watched this film probably you
know not long after it came out
um and then re-watching it last night
okay three hours seriously i was like
i don't think this movie needed to be
that long it doesn't have to be that
long it's so long but that that that's
the sex scene
kind of i was trying to figure out how i
felt about it while i was watching i was
like this is a little weird because
you know and she's she even says claire
for lonnie's susan says like it's like
making love with someone for the first
time
and you're just like okay like that's a
little weird
and then i was like wait you know what
though this is his first experience i'm
just gonna let it i'm just gonna let him
have it and the way it's like shot close
up on their face and it's like lip is
quick
almost crying
because he doesn't know what's happening
to himself he doesn't know what's
happening here it never looks that cool
i know from experience it never looks
that cool when it's your first time you
never have that question thomas newman
score isn't sweeping in while it's
happening
much more naked gun than anything else
your first time but
and
i i was so upset when that scene
happened and they didn't kick into the
foreigner song feels like the first time
and
it was all janine i'm sure you know this
because i think one of your ace
categories of maniac's categories in the
showdown was brad pitt movies martin
brest directed this movie who's famous
for directing the these like sort of
action comedies like beverly hills cop
and midnight run it's like it's an odd
choice the guy also did scent of a woman
so i can kind of see it but
meet joe black yeah it i wouldn't say
it's martin breast best work but i think
that he gets a lot out of this material
even if it took him a long time to get
there i think you know also i have to
say the performances in this movie
so you got brad you've got anthony
hopkins who by the way this might be one
of my favorite anthony hopkins movies i
know that's weird to say but he kills it
like a man knowing he's going to die
he's so good and the tension between him
and death and their agreement not to say
who he is
and the fact that and then he kind of
explodes and then when he finds out he's
like i'm in love with your daughter he's
like the [ __ ] you are
yeah you know he doesn't care like brad
pitt's giving him all these warnings and
he just he doesn't care like i was like
he's you're gonna take me anyway i don't
care and he's going to stand up to him i
love you yeah i mean did this man get
nominated for an oscar for this movie i
hope he did because dang
he's so good in it but you know who's
not so good in my opinion claire for
lonnie starts to kind of do the thing
like a little bit more intensely
throughout the whole what do you mean
joe i'm just gonna rely on my beauty and
you know yeah chill over here just like
what the hell is going on over here
why are and the whole time erin watched
it with me last night he was like her
eyes it looks like she's in pain
just like
joe
what are you what's going on you know
you're like okay get back to anthony and
brad
against a basically a hot ken doll i
don't know what she's supposed to do
because it's brad pitt but it's like
brad pitt with a four-year-old brain and
so you like
i understand everything that she's
feeling she's like this guy's so hot i'm
not gonna let him go but man do i have a
lot of clay to mold here oh gosh
true i'm looking at the i'm looking at
the box office for meet joe black right
now and meet joe black did
uh just under 45 million dollars worth
of business in the states it ended up
having a worldwide run of over 140
million dollars but there also is the
footnote here that meet joe black was
one of the few films showing the first
trailer for star wars the phantom menace
of star wars fans bought tickets for the
film only to leave after the trailer
showed here's the other thing you have
to know about 98 mark ellis is that me
and my friends went to go see this and
at the time again i'm much more of a
a more broad film appreciator than i
might have been back then
we were a bunch of of of horny teenagers
we didn't stay for the sex scene we
heard about the sex scene but just to
get to the sex scene was just too much
road to plow for us and
i didn't want to be seeing them make
love in a quivering lip from the first
time thinking about darth maul and the
double-sided lightsaber igniting so
i just i i remove myself from the
equation but i'm going to say rotten
tomatoes is wrong but not by much i
don't i think this might be i mean
i think it's probably taken down a bit
because of that caribbean accent oh my
gosh we have to talk about that please
do that is crazy okay
okay
you say it janine that was i literally
so when the when the grandma okay you
set it up because i can't
that's insane
he goes to visit claire fulani at the
hospital where she works and a jamaican
woman and her daughter come in and the
jamaican woman
i guess they're supposed to kind of hint
that she has some sensibility to kind of
tell that he is deaf so she feels that
he's an evil spirit
and uh she is talking in her you know
caribbean type accent and he replies to
her with his own caribbean accent
orbia
will be evil i'm not evil man
and what you is then
i'm from that next place
you're waiting here to take us
like is the bus driver to the air
and like lingo caribbean type like lingo
and it doesn't stop and he keeps doing
it and he kind of like
raises his voice and starts doing it and
my eyebrows shot into my hairline brad
pitt the risk taker brad pitt the risk
taker he commits i appreciate the
commitment i might have
tried it yeah i might have watched it a
couple different times because i don't
know why that isn't up there with like
all those embarrassing early acting
performances of people like we should be
talking about this scene more often than
we do
yes and
you know speaking of other weird scenes
and it's funny because what the movie
still somehow makes me feel a little
emotional about when it he comes back to
the hospital and she's like please take
me i want to die yeah there's all these
sort of beautiful the movie is back
crazy but in my favorite kind of way
it's unexpected you're like what the
hell is this about death takes a holiday
ultimately okay
and what's fabulous is that happens so
my eyebrows are in my hairline and then
the next thing you know i'm kind of like
tearing up a little bit
like i mean
the cnc has are really sweet and you
know this kind of understanding they
have and it's like the one person who
actually kind of knows who he is that he
can talk to that's not yelling at him
like anthony hopkins so like in in those
aspects like you get something out of
those scenes but it's just
it's just kind of weird it's really
weird i have two questions for y'all so
the opening well sort of the opening and
the ending so
the scene where he gets hit by the
double car like a double hit
thoughts about that and then at the end
did you guys cry when anthony finally
gets taken will parrot i didn't i didn't
cry janine but i i got i got a little
bit of feels in there and as far as the
the opening scene that's why you hire
martin bress to direct this movie
because that guy knows how to do
car action
[Music]
[Applause]
i remember first seeing that and it was
very shocking the first time i saw this
movie and that happened the double
because yeah you he almost gets hit and
then you kind of take a breather and
then immediately so i i like how they
kind of subverted your your thought on
that first kind of hit and then yes the
double hit so that was very shocking i
got something out of that that first
time uh watching it and the end no i
didn't cry but i definitely was emotion
i felt the emotions of that did your
brother cry when he got it on dhs i saw
a tear he will not admit it but i i saw
it okay okay well hopefully he's as
pretty of a crier as brad pitt is um
lucy i think janine and i are on the
same page where we we can go i'm not i'm
not gonna say fresh i'm gonna say hi
rotten for this movie are you on the
same page loose no this movie to me
should be in the 70s not certified fresh
necessary well i don't know i think this
i think rotten tomatoes is very wrong
about this score like very very wrong
and i
i might even say it could be like 75
certified fresh i love this movie
caribbean accent aside
very awkward
but um i do think there's there's so
much more that's well done about it
there are problems but there's so much
that's well done that i think it sort of
tips the scales for me i agree i think
it's a little it's i think it's i would
put it slightly higher than high rotten
i'd put it you know in in maybe
60 65 to 70 range okay i mean i i'm i'm
not going to lose any sleep over that
one the one that i will lose sleep over
is
listening to produce lucy now stump for
troy which is 53
it is the audience score is fresh it's
73 lucy troy how do you feel about this
movie ron tomatoes is wrong
it should be where the audience score is
which is what again it's like 70s or
something um
i think this should be like low 70s not
certified fresh but i think this movie
is actually
you know it's a hollywood blockbuster
film with brad pitt in it okay so you're
gonna get basic you know hollywood
blockbuster tropes we get it fine
whatever but i love historical movies
historical with quotes around the word
historical
and um i think why is because it's
incredibly memorable there are so many
scenes that are like i
i rewatched it last night as well but i
didn't really need to because i've
remembered so many of the scenes
one of the scenes in particular eric
banner and the brad pitt so achilles
versus hector duel so it's heartbreaking
because those two characters in my
opinion are the main
leads like you're rooting for both of
them right so it's kind of devastating
it's a beautiful fight they did it
themselves they did not have stunt
doubles
so that's incredible um and then the
sort of impact it has on achilles
afterwards where he's like oh maybe i
shouldn't have done that in my rage
because you killed my cousin garrett
headland aka police yeah on accident
yeah not realizing yeah there's just so
many things like that in the movie where
you're like it gets an emotional
reaction out of me
and then uh
you know scenes like when brad pitt so
achilles and his team of
awesome merry men i forget what they're
doing
the moment
the merman uh they go and they
ultimately have like a d day on the
beach of normandy but in troy and they
take over the a temple to apollo and
then they take um a girl captive and
it's played by rose byrne
and eventually brad pitt achilles has to
go talk to
agamemnon aka brian cox and he's a total
dick and he's like i stole your girl and
bread pit's like you sack of wine and
it's just things like that
that are so good
and i could just list a million things
so yes ron tomatoes is wrong tonight
i'll have her give me a bath
and then
who knows you sack of wine
before my time is done
i will look down on your corpse and
smile good is a strong word good is a
very strong word for those scenes i
i do like seeing brian cox as agamemnon
as like the the literal you know
greek version of uh logan roy from
succession but stealing this movie for
me is sean bean's portrayal of odysseus
i love seeing sean bean in this movie
that was the highlight he died he
doesn't die right i know we i was
waiting for it and and it never happened
i was like oh sweet we get out alive
here so janine for me
it's always fun to go and this is like
brad pitt you talk about like a physical
um
you talk about like a movie star kind of
prime this is him right during that apex
and so it is fun to go revisit something
like that i just never got a lot out of
these huge epics that were basically
watered-down versions of the like the
iliad the odyssey stuff like that i
thought that even like gladiator gliding
is a really good movie i don't hold it
up there with a lot of other folks where
they put the pedestal they put it on and
certainly i'm not going to do that for
troy even though i love wolfgang
peterson as a director for the most part
yeah i mean i'm not a huge sword and
sandal epic person but
i guess just the scale of this movie
really grabbed me and i remember being a
kid loving greek mythology and reading
books about it and you know hercules is
my favorite disney movie so um
yeah i really got into the action of
this movie i liked that they kind of
took out the mythical aspects of it like
the magical kind of things and creatures
and stuff and kind of made it feel like
a piece of history so i think that's why
i kind of was able to get into it more
um absolutely
love love love the scene with peter
o'toole coming to
achilles after hector's been killed and
kisses his hands and and that's what
makes achilles break down and feel
feel bad about what he's done when you
know the king comes to him and and that
speech that peter o'toole gives it's
just it's so good it's so good and of
course again like me latching on to the
romance and anything i'm like obsessed
with the whole kind of romeo and juliet
love affair of brussels and achilles so
does that hold up to you i mean that was
the thing that it never really popped
for me that romance never really did it
for me i i never felt like you know we
should really wage a war based on this i
i never felt like it was worthy of of of
the the scope of the movie i know we
have to have it just i i never i've seen
a lot of brad pitt romances where i'm
like yeah i need this to work this was
not one of them lucy well i felt like
i think i feel like that romance between
bruce and achilles however short it was
was more impactful than the main romance
that kind of leads to all of this
between
i'll give you that that's fair it was
the best in the movie for sure dude
orlando bloom's paris pisses me off so
bad i'm like you started this [ __ ]
everybody died because of you you're
awesome
you get to survive and you get it you
get a shoot which is cheating okay you
shoot the greatest warrior with arrows
which easy kill okay not cool and and he
goes off in the end and that really
affected me when i was younger when i
first watched i was so angry and um i
was in love with orlando bloom too
because of the lord of the rings so i
was like legless you effing bastard
lucy we need to get to the bottom of
this what is your hatred with orlando
bloom stemming from
well first off i think it's because i
was betrayed because when i was in
i forget maybe high school i watched the
lord of the rings movies immediately was
like legolas is my boyfriend i'm going
to meet him and marry him one day so
he's not actually an elf
so
so then i rewatched the lord of the
rings because i do it every year and as
i've gotten older i'm like oh
you're actually like the worst part of
this movie really
so there's a betrayal i think that i had
to go through and and kind of wake up
and so when i see him in this movie i'm
like okay
we've got peter o'toole killing it we've
got eric bana killing it brad pitt is
doing his brad pitt thing and killing it
for the most part um we've got sean bean
as odysseus killing it
everybody's killing it and then there's
orlando bloom who is kind of in my mind
like
playing himself you know he sucks and
then he's also paris so it's just i'm
very angry about it and oh and he's
doing the legolas thing where he's like
it's a blood moon there will be live
shed today but he's like helen i must go
and fight for you because i ran away the
first time you're just like she doesn't
even and she doesn't even believe him no
way
no this relationship is bad like the way
he talks about like when they're in that
scene together and he's like i will
fight for your honor i'll fight for you
i'll fight him for you and she's just
like sure she had like her face
she's like you're a wife stealer uh
even though i was the wife and i was
dead
you're not trustworthy
which oh brendan gleason is good brendan
gleason is great in this movie sean
bean's great in this movie there there's
some performances to take away from it
and and like we talked about with edward
zwick making the legends of the fall
feel as epic as he does i think wolfgang
peterson achieves that for sure like
this is a huge historical epic i think
that y'all are trying to get me to say
that rotten tomatoes is right by saying
that it's up to 53
just based on how much fun you can have
watching this movie i can't get the
movie there i'm so sorry i'm i think
this movie i think i'm being nice as
possible i think this movie and meet joe
black should trade places i think this
movie goes down to 45 percent of the
time and meet joe black goes up to 53
i agree but not with your scores i think
troy is the lowest one out of these
three films i think me joe black it for
me is
probably number two and then legends of
the fall is number one but they all just
janine wins the show
definitely of course she yeah
yeah and i think i think i got to pick
the movie first i think we were doing
this episode and i told lucy like last
year i'm like oh when we do that meet
joe black's my movie and then janine
comes in swinging with
legends of the fall and i'm like oh man
okay i think i lost this hand here so
brad pitt an actor for all times he's
one of the biggest movie stars of all
time so we wanted to come on here and
talk about some of his films that
if they're not the most talked about
movies we just wanted to deliver them
justice if they deserve it and i feel
like legends of the fall was helped out
by this show and i feel like troy and me
joe black were um you know also here so
they
also showed up for the ride and uh
showing up today is our our our
two-pronged special guest of janine
bryce and perducy lucy producee lucy i
think the kids know where to find you on
this program each and every week doing
the lord's work janine where can
everybody find you in all your exploits
i know that it's a wonderful life it's a
wonderful podcast it's it's like a feat
so you all get to talk about a lot of
different stuff on there yes so we also
have our youtube channel where we have a
brand new show monday madness uh i
co-host all these shows with my adorable
british friend morgan robinson
monday madness we just kind of have fun
we pick a random topic discuss play
games so it's a really fun time over
there janine thanks so much for being on
the show i can't it's hard to believe
we've done 100 of these shows and this
is your first time but please come back
thank you for having me
and and educate me and producing lucy
more because as you can tell we need it
and producing lucy thank you too for for
you know kind of wearing two hats today
for producing and contributing to
oh it was easy peasy lemon squeezy
because he's so nice in the meantime
that was janine bryce i still know
janine the machine janine de bean but
she is she she's a jeanine for all
seasons that is perdusi lucy engineer
brian perez who's seen once upon a time
in hollywood more than just about any
other movie and for the whole gang here
at rotten tomatoes including my lovely
co-host jack mccully i am the not as
lovely mark ellis thanks for watching or
listening to this episode and i don't
know how to leave us with a brad pitt
quote other than saying i'm hungry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you